maybe they're a chore to sit through
perhaps they're just too disturbing or
maybe they're so emotionally traumatic
that they left us weeping on the floor
for days from melodramatic war movies to
stunning but slow-moving sci-fi these
are the greatest movies will never watch
again war is hell and while no film can
truly capture the horrors of battle The
Deer Hunter does a pretty good job of
taking moviegoers into the ninth circle
this 1978 epic follows a trio of
blue-collar steel workers who can't wait
to see action in Vietnam but when they
finally descend into the jungle they're
put through the worst tortures
imaginable and the trauma doesn't stop
once they come back home the movie opens
innocently enough with our three leads
Mike Nick and Steven celebrating at a
wedding and joyously preparing for war
they ignore the grim warning from a
shaken Green Beret and when they're
finally tossed into the jungle they wind
up smack dab in one of the most horrific
movie scenes of all time the Russian
Roulette sequence captured by the
Vietcong the friends are forced to play
the suicidal game for the amusement of
their guards and the acting here is so
intense that it feels like a genuine
snuff film all David Lynch movies feel a
little dreamlike but Inland Empire is
pure subconscious surrealism a cinematic
fugue state that lasts over three hours
it's like you've stumbled straight into
Lynch's worst nightmares the movie isn't
impenetrably slow descent into a world
of red lights ambient noises and digital
camera work and while you can always
appreciate Lynch's avant-garde genius
Inland Empire provides more questions
than answers the Baltic region
what's that got to do with you for some
fans this might sound like an awesome
experience but for most moviegoers
Inland Empire feels like the world's
worst acid trip it's definitely worth
watching once but when it's over you
might be too overwhelmed to give it
another shot in the killing of a sacred
deer Colin Farrell plays a heart surgeon
named Stephen Murphy whose fondness for
the bottle contributed to the death of a
patient Stephen refuses to admit any
wrongdoing and that's just not going to
sit with the patient's son an unusual
team by the name of Martin lang your son
tell me that you've got lots of hair
under your arms three times more than I
do and that you've got very back there's
something off about Martin and that's
before he reveals his godlike power to
enact revenge on Stephens entire family
as part of his revenge scheme Martin
tells Stephen all his family members are
going to die of a mysterious illness
they'll become paralyzed and then
they'll refuse to eat and after they
start bleeding from their eyes they'll
die the only way Stephen can stop this
plague is by killing a member of his
family the movie gets even darker when
the family turns on each other arguing
why they shouldn't be the one to die the
desperation the betrayal the blood it's
also cruel and it culminates in one of
the most disturbing climaxes ever filmed
horrific in ways that no slasher film
could ever achieve the killing of a
sacred deer is a powerful film that you
won't watch more than once instead
you'll want to put a curse on whoever
recommended the film to you in the first
place I see the only thing I can think
of as close to justice released in 2011
kill list follows Jay a soldier turned
assassin who's fallen on hard times he's
got money problems relationship troubles
and some serious PTSD but things start
looking up when he gets a gig to pick
off three easy targets however whenever
he shows up to put a cap in his victims
they start thanking him for the
privilege of dying by his hand it's more
than a little unsettling and soon Jay
realizes he's in the center of an occult
conspiracy that demands a lot of blood
and some really big sacrifices kill list
is an all-out assault on the senses not
only is it one of the most suspenseful
movies ever made but it's filled with
disturbing sequences the final showdown
with a group of naked pagans is pure
nightmare fuel but it's the final few
minutes that will leave
Raeleen arachnophobia where if
eight-legged creatures give you the
willies then you might want to stay far
away from enemy directed by denis
villeneuve this eerie thriller is full
of spider imagery shot in a sickly
yellow hue enemy stars Jake Gyllenhaal
as a college professor who's made an
unsettling discovery after renting a
particular film he spots an actor who
looks exactly like him eventually the
two doppelgangers collide and let's just
say they don't become best of friends
actor Gyllenhaal is a grim and violent
man and pulse depressed and weary
professor Gyllenhaal deeper and deeper
into his web of Darkness playing two
roles Gyllenhaal makes your skin crawl
with his characters engaging in all
sorts of unsavory activities enemy is a
film that's likely to make you queasy
and uneasy and that's even before you
get to the absolutely horrifying ending
scene based on a tragic true event
Fruitvale station tells the story of
Oscar Grant a 22 year old man who was
killed by a Bay Area Rapid Transit
officer in 2009 we watch Oscar bonding
with his daughter in connecting with
strangers we see him smile and laugh
full of life sure he's got some issues
but he's a sincere guy trying to make
things better and what hurts is that we
know he'll never get that chance
director Ryan Coogler does an excellent
job of showing Oscar as a living
breathing human not just a statistic he
loves feels pain makes mistakes and
affect so many people but all his
chances for a brighter future are
brought to a bloody halt when he's shot
in the back for absolutely no reason he
leaves behind a child a girlfriend and a
mother a human being bleeds to death on
New Year's Day and as Fruitvale station
comes to an end we're not just depressed
we're mourning a life that was taken far
too soon in Manchester by the C Casey
Affleck plays Li Chandler a handyman
who's cut himself off from the world
the only time he interacts with people
is when he's picking fights at the bar
however Li is forced out of hiding when
his brother dies from cardiac arrest
naturally Li has to return to his
hometown to arrange the funeral and care
for his nephew Patrick eventually we
discover why Li hates his hometown and
why he's a depressed angry shell of a
man one evening after a night of
drinking li accidentally started a fire
that killed his two kids unable to deal
with the pain li divorced his wife and
done his best to disappear for a moment
it seems like the bond he's forming with
his nephew might save him from his past
but this isn't a hallmark movie in the
last act li admits the truth to Patrick
I can't beat it sorry
as much as he cares for his nephew he
can't overcome his depression and guilt
there are no easy solutions or feel-good
endings here and while Manchester by the
sea is a beautiful film wallowing and
all that misery a second time sounds
like the most painful two hours you
could ever spend
directed by Denis Villeneuve Blade
Runner 2049 is one of the most gorgeous
movies ever made a worthy follow-up to
the 1982 original this stunning sequel
nabbed cinematographer Richard Deakins
the Oscar award he's always deserved
from its barren desert wastelands to its
neon Holograms
20:49 is a visually rich world of
replicants and artificial intelligence
all beautifully bathed in smog and city
lights
however it's not exactly what you'd call
a fast paced film in fact you might even
call it a slog the movie follows Ryan
Gosling as Kay a Blade Runner who
stumbles across a mystery that might
revolutionize the entire world crazier
still he might be at the center of a
vast conspiracy and during his quest for
the truth he meets the original Blade
Runner himself
Rick Deckard but ylk does indeed solve
the mystery the film takes its sweet
time in getting to the answers while
Blade Runner 2049 is a fantastic work of
science fiction it runs almost three
hours long and even thinking about
rewatching that might be enough to make
you a little sleepy after winding up in
the world's scariest club the members of
a punk rock band stumble across a
particularly nasty murder scene knowing
the alt-right owners aren't going to let
them walk away the band members locked
themselves in the titular room and
prepare for war but jujitsu will only
get you so far when your opponents are
walking around with pistols and pit
bulls with our heroes completely
outmatched greenroom quickly devolves
into a gore soaked nightmare of ripped
out throats and nearly severed limbs
unlike a lot of other horror films the
deaths in green room aren't at all fun
these kids are screaming in genuine pain
as their mangled by dogs and hacked by
machetes greenroom is fantastic but at
its core the movie is as mean and
nihilistic as cinema gets
and while the rockers eventually take
their revenge so much blood gets
splattered on the walls by the end that
it should probably be renamed Red Room a
passion project for Martin Scorsese
silence features no gangsters no dirty
cops and no taxi driving assassins
instead the story follows two Jesuit
priests father Rodriguez and father guru
pay as they head to Japan to find a
missing priest father Ferreira steadfast
in his faith Rodriguez is tested when he
falls into the hands of a ruthless
Japanese governor practicing
Christianity in Japan was punishable by
death in the 17th century but the
governor doesn't just want to murder
this priest he wants to break his spirit
and make him renounce his beliefs just
because on top of the physical torment
father Rodriguez is in constant
spiritual pain should he recant and damn
his soul to save the lives of others and
in the midst of all this pain why is God
so silent whether you're a believer or
an atheist silence is a painful reminder
that faith is never easy and the silence
of the universe is the most painful
torture of all we have an only edition
battery pity you didn't not notice it we
just think a different way
[Music]